what is 0/0 this question is trending
right now because Apple engineers
included an Easter Egg on the iPhone if
you ask this question to Siri you will
get the following response imagine that
you have zero cookies and you split them
evenly among zero friends how many
cookies does each person get see it
doesn't make sense
and Cookie Monster said that there are
no cookies and you are sad that you have
no friends
while Siri gives a sarcastic response
the answer that 0/0 is indeterminate is
considered an acceptable answer so
what's the problem with dividing by zero
one problem is if we could divide by
zero we get contradictory results we
know that one times zero is equal to two
times zero because any number times zero
is equal to zero if we could divide by
zero the way we normally divide by other
numbers or if zero had a multiplicative
inverse then we could divide this
equation by zero and cancel out the
zeros to find that one equals two this
would clearly ruin everything we know
about mathematics and this would cause
algebra to be meaningless we can in fact
have this for any numbers a and B that a
times zero equals B times zero and when
we divide by zero or multiply by the
multiplicative inverse we get a equals B
so one reason we can't divide by zero is
that it wouldn't be a meaningful
operation relative to the rest of
algebra and mathematics that we built up
but Siri said that zero dividing by zero
is indeterminate so what does that mean
well think about dividing one by smaller
and smaller decimals if you take
positive decimals you will eventually
get that one divided by these smaller
and smaller positive decimals will be
plus infinity graphically as we approach
zero from positive numbers the graph
keeps on going up to
positive infinity if you did the
operation from negative numbers as you
got smaller and smaller and closer to
zero you'd get one divided by these
numbers is negative infinity and the
graph goes the other way so what happens
when you divide exactly at zero well the
limit approaches both plus infinity and
negative infinity and therefore we say
the limit is indeterminate and that's
another problem with dividing by zero so
Siri does give the correct answer
although it is accompanied by the
sarcastic response I hope you like this
video please subscribe to my channel I
make videos on math and game theory you
can catch me on my blog mind your
decisions which you can follow on
Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
also catch me at pressure Locker on
social media and please check out my
books there's a link in the video
description thanks for watching